thank you
good afternoon and welcome to our media
briefing to kick off the 20 20 21 flu
season
my name is heidi parker i am the
executive director of immunized nevada
a statewide nonprofit that promotes
health and prevents disease
today you will hear from a variety of
leaders and public health
representatives our governor
the board of health vice chair our chief
health officer
the nevada minority health and equity
coalition
and the unlv school of medicine
they are committing to lead by example
to protect nevada
by preventing influenza especially in
our communities
that are at the most risk and most
vulnerable to complications from the flu
we ask that all health care business
education
community and other leaders do the same
you will also hear today how the flu
vaccine is more important than ever
during this pandemic we can all arm
ourselves
with a safe and effective vaccine while
we continue
to stop the spread and flatten the curve
of coven 19.
we are grateful for the governor's
leadership and for rolling up his sleeve
to protect himself his family and his
community
so without further ado governor sislek
thank you
thank you heidi for those kind words and
for the introduction
uh and for your work with immunized
nevada
and the southern nevada health district
to organize this important event that
we're here
for today today i'm here to remind all
nevadans of the importance
of getting a flu shot this year more
than
ever before as we continue
to work to slow the spread of covet 19.
a flu shot is a powerful tool to help
make sure
we are all staying healthy
getting a flu shot helps protect you
from the flu
and it helps protect our health care
system which are
continuing to treat covid19 patients
we want to ensure that our healthcare
system have enough personnel
equipment and capacity to treat all
patients
and by getting a flu shot you are doing
your part
to help us in that effort if all
nevadans get a flu shot
we can help keep thousands of patients
out of the hospital this season
and that will be a critical step to
helping our state
and our doctors and nurses who have been
working around the clock since
since march that's over six months
helping us fight the covid 19 pandemic
we owe them all an eternal debt of
gratitude for their efforts on the front
line
we do not want to see a huge surge in
flu cases
on top of covet 19 cases overcrowding
our hospitals
and preventing nevadans from getting the
care we need
flu shots are easy and they're painless
and today my wife kathy and i both will
get our flu shots
to ensure we are protected this flu
season
the cdc and our own public health
officials
recommend that everyone six months and
older
get a flu shot every year i certainly
qualify in the six months or over
if you have questions about what kind of
flu shot to get
and what is right for you please talk to
your doctor
or other health care professional to get
their advice and opinions
finally i know we're here today to talk
about the importance of a flu vaccine
but i also want to take a moment
to remind nevadans that covet 19 is
still among us
and we need to remain vigilant more than
ever
please if you were out and about this
labor day weekend
in a large crowd or with people from
outside of your household
please get a covet test
even if you have no symptoms today
please
go get a kova test the more people we
test
and right now we have the stop swab and
go available
the more people we test the more we can
do to bring positivity down
if you want to attend a theater if you
want to attend the movies
if you want our restaurants and bars
open back up if you want to be able to
go to a golden knights game or raiders
game
we need to bring our numbers down you
getting a
covid test help us accomplish that goal
and i implore you everyone who has not
gotten one to please avail yourself of
the opportunity
and go get a covid test
clark county surge testing called as i
said stop swap and go
is now on until september 18th
an extension of almost a full week
that's in addition to the regular
testing sites that are available in
clark county
nevadans across the state can visit the
nevada health response website
at nvhealthresponse.nv.gov to find a
testing locator map
to find a site near you i also want to
encourage everyone to sign up for the
app on your phone
uh vada test and i should look up the
name of it here
covid trace if you put it on your phone
it will help drastically for us to be
able to trace contact with someone who
might have been
positive it takes no effort it's free
if you go to the app store to cover
trace put it on your phone
and it'll help our health care
professionals trace
who you might have been in contact with
who might have been in contact with you
unknowingly
and you might have been exposed and will
prevent the disease from spreading
so i encourage you first to go get a
test
at stop swap and go or one of our other
sites and to put covet trace on your
phone
on that app thanks for coming and i will
now turn it over to my friend
and colleague from the clark county
commission chairwoman marilyn
kirkpatrick
commissioner
good afternoon and thank everybody for
coming today
and i apologize my voice is a little bit
groggy that wind's a little bit rough
out there today
uh but uh first and foremost
this really is a pleasure for me as a
southern nevada health district board
member
i serve as the vice chair of health
district
and this is really what we do every
single year is we remind people to get
out
get your flu shots stay healthy i carry
my hand sanitizer
with me all the time we remind the
little ones to
wash their hands diligently if you have
a runny nose
be sure to stay clean and stay hydrated
but today really is about what we do as
a
public health agency and that is
encouraging people to get out
and get their flu shots to get ahead of
it
for this fall season secondly we do
immunizations for all of our little ones
and
as the governor pointed out um we
encourage people to go get their coven
19 testing because the more that we can
have people
test and that's your whole family from
your smallest one
to your oldest one and encourage them to
get testing because that's how we stay
on top of the spread
but today encourage everybody to go out
and get your flu shot i am going to be
getting my flu shot
with the governor and the first lady
today so
do your part for our community stay
healthy as we go into the fall
and we will all get our flu shots and
they are available
across the valley so with that i'm going
to turn it over to
dr bermane lagann
dr lagann
the southern nevada healthy street
wants to remind everyone about the
importance of the flu vaccination
every year we we do a lot of work with
with the flu vaccine here in the county
we we partner with
multiple groups also we have a
mobile unit that go to multiple places
across the county
and we offer the vaccine we also
receive a certain amount of
free flu vaccine for adults
and children that we distribute across
the county
i also want to mention the the
importance of the flu vaccination
this year especially when we are still
fighting
the kobe pandemic and the risk of
of having above the flu and
alcohol hitting our communities
especially for those members of our
community who are
suffering other diseases
or conditions such as diabetes
immune depressive conditions some sort
you know cancer
hiv and other depressive conditions are
actually
putting in a risk of suffering
a severe complication from both the flu
and call it so if every year is
important to have
the flu vaccine this year is even more
important
you want to say that
we also
we also want to mention that
the southern nevada healthy street will
be offering the flu vaccine
at this facility and also our facilities
in east las vegas henderson
and other sites across the across the
country
and our mobile unit will be
offering the vaccine at multiple
locations we have
a agreement with
county libraries in las vegas
and henderson and other areas where also
we go
and offer the vaccine and just in
closing i want to say
i remember everybody that the flu shot
save lives and especially this year
it's not just about the flu also it's
about kobe
and making sure that our loved ones are
not
affected by any of those diseases thank
you
good afternoon everyone my name is jose
malendras and i am the executive
director
for the office of community partnerships
at the university school of public
health
and i also currently serve as chair of
the nevada minority health and equity
coalition
we are committed to supporting the
public health system in nevada
that is inclusive and mindful of all
diversity and equity populations and
that is the kind of effort that we need
right now
to make sure that we're involving
everybody in this effort to get their
flu shots
uh we supported public health system and
those who needed to recognize and
respect economic racial and social
impact in our communities i want to take
this opportunity also
to thank governor sisolak for his
leadership and courage
in declaring racism a public health
issue we appreciate the governor
thank you to heidi from immunized nevada
and government system providing here
today to share this critical message
about immunization
like our leader of the health district
we all know that health care
is a barrier in getting an annual flu
vaccination especially in our vulnerable
populations
we know that these communities have
increased rates of diabetes hypertension
cardiovascular disease
kidney disease and other underlying
health conditions that leave them more
susceptible to severe illnesses
associated with influenza during this
especially during this challenging time
that is more compounded by the culvert
19.
in addition these populations are
overrepresented in settings serving on
the front lines as essential workforce
in essential workforce positions
thus increasing their exposure in the
current pandemic
numerous studies show that african
american latinos as well as native
americans pacific islanders lgbtqia
and others are impacted and need to be
vaccinated for the influenza
shot the unova school of public health
and the nevada minority health and
equity coalition support the efforts
of immunized nevada and the leadership
of governor sisalek to encourage all
nevadans to get their flu shots this
season
if not for yourself then do it for the
ones you love be safe and stay healthy
and i did get my flu shot two weeks ago
so thank you good afternoon
my name is jabrie vallan i'm a second
year medical student at the university
of nevada las vegas school of medicine
as well as co-president or a chapter of
the student national medical association
the unlv school of medicine and the snma
are committed to graduating socially and
culturally competent positions
who contend to the healthcare needs of
our diverse population here in nevada
thank you immunized nevada and governor
syslak for having me here today
like mr melinda's i want to make a few
points about vaccines and healthcare
access from
minority groups access to healthcare is
an identified barrier in getting an
annual flu shot
especially in our minority and
impoverished populations
during the 2018-2019 flu season only 22
percent of our black population and 36.2
of our hispanic population receive flu
shots we're implementing innovative
evidence-based strategies
to address these inequities and flu
vaccinations and make this a public
health priority
however this is a multi-faceted effort
and we need the help of community
leaders
and the general public i'd like to share
a story of my personal experience
administering flu shots in the community
for the past few years students from the
unlv school of medicine with the help of
additional community healthcare
professionals
have hosted free flu shot clinics at the
agassi boys and girls club
the club is located in west las vegas
where health services are few and far
between
in our 2019 clinic we administered about
75 flu shots
to parents children and other community
members in about a four hour span
this was a huge success that was mostly
attributable to gaining the public's
trust
through education and working alongside
great community leaders
we created a flyer that stressed the
importance of receiving a flu shot and
we took the time to
educate those who arrive with questions
however some people were so apprehensive
the agassi boys and girls club is led by
mr james smith someone i personally hold
in a high regard
you know and i know many other community
members feel the same way
mr smith volunteered to get his flu shot
before everyone else after witnessing mr
smith receive his shot
the kids and their parents became more
receptive to receiving their own
we also made it a point to give parents
their shots before their children to
provide another example
of someone they trust doing the right
thing when people arrive later in the
clinic mr smith would show him his
band-aid and assure them that it didn't
hurt
like mr smith and governor assist like
today we all need to be we all need to
embody the change that we wish to see
around us
healthcare professionals will continue
to do their part to promote public
health we also need community leaders
to rally around and champion our public
health initiatives
business owners managers teachers
coaches heads of households and all
other community stakeholders
we need you to get a free vaccination
this fall and encourage those around you
to do the same thing stay safe nevada
thank you
thank you to all of our speakers that
joined us today
just that reminder of all nevadans can
do their part
to help protect our state our community
their families
and governor sisselok is going to now
get his flu shot
along with the first lady and then some
of our other speakers as well today so
thank you all for being here and then
we'll transition
over to the area of flu shots thank you
this
so
absolutely
come on up after you
you're smart you think you had to wear a
short sleeve shirt
right
right
so
so
i just don't know it's your first time
i guess they wanted me to ask if anybody
had any questions while you've got us
gathered here does anybody have any
questions
jeff's always got a question
okay
yes
it's a big concern that we have and i'm
confident that with the work that the
health district is doing and
collaborating with the county who i give
an awful lot of credit for getting out
front on this
if we can just educate people it's
painless the flu shot absolutely
painless
and it will protect you especially i
just said as you get a little older
like me not so much my wife from
maryland but as you get a little older
it's important you protect yourself
every way you possibly can so it's
definitely beneficial and
and our frontline workers are nurses
doctors hospital staff
medical students have been doing the
health district have been doing
incredible work for better than six
months now dealing with covet 19 and the
last thing we need to do is
overwhelm a health care system with the
flu epidemic so
uh it's an easy thing to do it's
something you can be proactive on i
encourage everybody to do it
i do attribute it to some of the
protocols we've put in place and i
commend the county for their help in
enforcing
some of the mandates that we put in
place the idea of wearing masks avoiding
large gatherings
social distancing washing your hands
keeping safe
is definitely helping us to bring the uh
the numbers down and the kova track app
on your phones
is helping us identify new cases we're
really excited about the stop swap and
go
that you can we can test more people the
more people we test
the more we'll be able to bring our
positivity numbers down and the
quicker we're going to be able to get to
opening things so we're hopeful that the
numbers continue to come down
uh we just got through labor day weekend
and hopefully we'll get through without
any major hiccups along the way but
that's our hope
yeah the flu shots are made available
free if you can't if you don't have
insurance to pay for them i mean as the
medical students saying we went into the
minority communities they went into
legacy boys and girls club and
and that's great we need to get our
mobile units into those areas to provide
them for folks
uh sometimes people if you haven't
gotten one before
you're a little intimidated but there's
no reason to be intimidated it's a very
simple process and
we'll do a big outreach in of our
african-american community and our
hispanic community to make sure that
they have available and they know
they're available
else thanks everybody